again you watching Cape early breakfast
he was once the most powerful man in
Hollywood and it was often said that
he'd been thanked in Oscar speeches more
times than God now the name Harvey
Weinstein tends to evoke more anger than
appreciation the sexual abuse
allegations against him which first
appeared in The New York Times two years
ago helped bring about the me2 movement
mr. Weinstein has also denied all
accusations of non-consensual sex but
the campaign sparked by the allegations
against him prompted thousands of women
to come forward with their own accounts
of sexual harassment and assault a new
book titled she said has been published
detailing the work of the two New York
Times investigative journalists I can
never say that word who broke this story
early Cantor bless you and also Meghan
Terry who are both with us now hello to
you thank you both for joining us on the
program what was the aim of the book
what was it what was the yeah well we
realized when that that first story that
we published in October of 2017 was
actually just the beginning we had been
able to connect some of the dots about
this alleged predator and how he'd been
able to cover his tracks but since then
in the course of reporting this book
we've been able to bring together so
many other pieces of the puzzle we've
been able to pull the curtain back on
the machinery that was in place to
silence women these secret settlements
that have also legally prohibited women
victims from telling their stories
and we've also been able to go more in
depth on these sort of gut-wrenching
decisions that the brave women who
participated in our investigation we're
facing as they decided whether or not to
go on the record what sort of challenges
did you face along the way that's what
part of we wanted to show people in the
book because doing an investigation like
this is not easy and these events have
come to mean so much to so many people
that we're trying to show this
step-by-step process of how you uncover
these secrets how you confront a bully
so we want you there with us as we have
these initial conversations with
actresses as you meet the sort of secret
source the there was a bit of a deep
throat figure in the Weinstein
investigation Weinstein's own accountant
of 30 years and throughout the story the
question of who helped and who hindered
turns out to be a very surprising
for example one of our earliest and most
loyal sources was winneth Paltrow and
all of this was off the record for so
long it's only recently that we've been
able to reveal in this book what
actually happened and how challenging
was it for you to sort of you know lift
the veil if you will because he he was a
very powerful man as I said in the
introduction thank more times than God
at Oscar ceremonies he had high-profile
lawyers he had private investigators and
he wasn't having it right no you're
absolutely right I mean we encountered
one challenge after the other in the
course of this reporting I think
probably one of the most severe
challenges that we faced were these
secret settlements that have been used
in cases of sexual harassment and sexual
assault not just in the case of
Weinstein but in cases across the
country across the United States across
the UK in cases of sexual harassment and
sexual assault so for example in the
summer of 2017 I was able to track down
a woman we kind of considered her the
patient zero of the Weinstein story who
had been allegedly sexually assaulted by
him in 1990 when she was working as a
young assistant in his first company
right out of college and when I knocked
on her door she said I've been waiting
for somebody to knock on this my door
for 25 years but but like so many other
women who had come forward with
allegations over the years she was
legally prohibited from talking to us
because of a secret settlement also I
think what many people don't realize is
that the UK was ground zero in many ways
for our investigation there's this kind
of image of the Weinstein victim as a
famous actress in a ball ground and
that's true as far as it goes but there
were women in the UK who were essential
to bringing the truth to light
Laura Madden and Zelda Perkins both
former Miramax assistants who worked for
Weinstein many many years ago both
played incredibly brave roles Zelda
Perkins was the first woman to speak to
us who had an NDA and who actually
showed us her settlement papers which
were so severe she ended up being the
first woman in the world to break her
and EA against Weinstein publicly and
you know the cold haven't you thank you
very much traveling a lot yeah
Joe and Laura Madden actually Laura
Madden who lives quietly in Swansea
Wales was one of the first two women to
go on the record with Ashley Judd about
Weinstein's experiences and just to show
you Laura's courage she did it under
incredibly difficult circumstances as
our story was growing closer Laura had
just had breast cancer and needed some
reconstructive surgery after the breast
cancer and the publication of the story
and her surgery ended up pretty much
coinciding and she still went on the
record that's how brief she was I mean
it gathered this meaty campaign that
came off the back of your investigation
gathered a momentum that was difficult
to anticipate a Pandora's box of sexual
harassment as it's been described it
involved hundreds of men in every walk
of life it empowered women to come
forward and say me too quite literally
with the hashtag but what do you say to
those who suggest that it it emasculated
young men who were caught up in this
sort of tsunami of me2 furia didn't feel
that you know they felt that they were
in somewhere being as I said him ask you
later
well you're absolutely right that it was
within days of our story being published
that our phones and our emails were
flooded with women who are coming
forward with their own stories of sexual
harassment and abuse that happened not
just at the New York Times but in news
organizations across the United States
and around the world and also you had so
many victims who just basically took to
social media under the me2 hashtag and
so it was another reason that we wanted
to write this book she said was because
we wanted to push we wanted to go beyond
the breaking of the Weinstein story into
the year that followed as it became more
complicated and more confusing we really
feel like there are three pressing and
yet unresolved questions that have left
everybody feeling frustrated one what
what is the what is the scope of
behavior that's under scrutiny are we
only talking about serious allegations
of rape and sexual assaults or are we
talking about some of the more nuanced
uncomfortable interactions that men and
women have and also how far back are we
going are we talking about allegations
that can go back to say the 1980s
secondly what is our process
for vetting these complaints you know we
walk readers through all of the like
specific due diligence that we do an
investigative journalism but for HR
departments and for the court of public
opinion what are the standards that were
applying to determine what actually
happened and finally you know what what
about the question of accountability
it's much easier to insist on
accountability than it is to assign it
so we have found that those three
questions oftentimes get basically
jumbled together and leave everybody
feeling like there has not been kind of
adequate reforms and answers to make
sure that everybody feels like they're
being treated fairly
understood and and to that end talking
about fair treatment harvey weinstein of
course has not been found guilty of
anything at this stage his court case is
at the beginning of next year and he's
still passionate about in new york
living his life he is and you know this
trial is a very uncertain thing because
both of the prosecution and the defense
have had problems coming in to trial so
you know many people assume that he'll
be convicted because the number of women
who have come out against him is so
overwhelming and yeah and i would urge
everyone to just wait and see what
happens and you know not make any
predictions because if you think of your
assumptions exactly you know it's
innocent until proven guilty absolutely
and if you look at the ocean of
complaints against Harvey Weinstein most
of those are for sexual harassment and
you can't go to jail in the UK or the US
for sexual harassment it's illegal under
civil law not criminal law there's a
smaller island of rape and assault
allegations against Weinstein but it's a
really only two women stories that are
at the basis of this trial we still
don't know everything about these
stories and just remember that the
sexual assault cases are very hard to
prove in court yeah and it's for a jury
to decide whether or not he is guilty in
the meantime he he has his Liberty in
New York and you have your book out
which is out soon it's out now that now
fantastic well thank you very much
indeed for coming in to speak to us on
the program and I wish you better thank
you
those aeroplanes are a nightmare